alan weiss solberg acepto 15 cargos de
fraude fiscal en los que acepta la culpa
de haber ayudado entre otros a crear un
esquema de evasión tributaria en la
organización de los trump a cambio de
esto el jefe financiero habría recibido
17 millones de dólares
carlos de lujo pago de renta de un
apartamento de manhattan y la educación
gratuita para algunos de sus nietos al
aceptar los cargos acepta también un
acuerdo de culpabilidad con la oficina
del fiscal de nueva york y tendrá que
pagar cinco meses de cárcel y no dos
años si declara la verdad en el próximo
juicio contra la organización de los
trump en octubre el acuerdo en este
acuerdo disolver que no tendrá sin
embargo que declarar en contra de trump
o de la organización de los trompos y
por ende la aceptación de cargos y de
acuerdo de culpabilidad no representan
inmediatamente consecuencias legales
para el ex presidente desde que salió de
la casa blanca' recordemos trump tiene
varias investigaciones criminales y
civiles en su contra entre ellas sí
declaró valores falsos de sus
propiedades para acceder a créditos
financieros más grandes si trump trató
de interferir y manipular los resultados
electorales
oficiales electorales de georgia en las
elecciones presidenciales pasadas si
rompe tiene o no responsabilidad en los
ataques al capitolio del 6 de enero y la
más reciente investigación sobre por qué
el ex presidente se quedó con
información confidencial y se la llevó a
su mansión de mar al agua en la florida
de hecho que llevó al fbi a allanar su
residencia de generado tanta polémica de
hecho hoy se llevó a cabo una audiencia
para aprobar la publicación de más
información sobre lo que el fbi encontró
en málaga